you don't need to want to be the best in
the world at something you don't need to
want to make a lot of money you don't
need to want to be an entrepreneur like
all they're literally just stand-ins
their proxies for fulfillment and energy
creation if when I say work hard long
and smart that doesn't feel right to you
and you don't want to do that by all
means don't do that in any pursuit of
greatness in any endeavor where you're
trying to gain mastery you're gonna get
bored because practice is repetition
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's heaven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up in a
morbidly obese family and being dead
broke to building a billion-dollar brand
and now wanting to pull people out of
the matrix he's Tom bill you and here's
my take on his top 10 rose to success
volume 4 enjoy
okay let's pick it off with rule number
one be fulfilled by what you're doing
there isn't a better way to live your
life there's no right way and wrong way
there is only the way that gives you
more energy there is only the way that
gives you fulfillment when you have
those things when you're fulfilled by
what you're doing and it's giving you
the heart you pursue it it's giving you
more energy you're on the right path as
the Greeks would say say though say goal
of the Roma I can't believe I messed
that up say goal of the Roma which means
you're on a good road and that's what I
want people to understand like yes I pj
r i preach a very specific path but i
don't think that it is a universal path
and so the only universal path is to do
the things that give you fulfillment and
energy so if spending time with your
friends gives you that then you should
be spending more time with your friends
if dating gives you that then you should
be dating so you don't need to want to
be the best in the world at something
you don't need to want to make a lot of
money you don't need to want to be an
entrepreneur like all there literally
just stand-ins their proxies for
fulfilment and energy creation that's it
so those are the punch lines of what's
the meaning of life and all of that
stuff it is to do something that makes
you feel a deep sense of well-being
which i'll call fulfillment and
something that gives you energy where
you're literally excited to attack the
day rule number two optimise life for
yourself there's no obligation to work
hard smart and long hours do whatever
you want that at the end of the day this
is all about
neuro chemistry it's about feeling good
about who you are it's about loving your
life it's about fulfillment it's it's
really just enjoying this one chance
that you get at this life and so if when
I say work hard long and smart that
doesn't feel right to you and you don't
want to do that by all means don't do
that my whole thing is if you want to be
the best if you want to play in a world
stage if you want to outperform if you
want to get extraordinary results the
reality is if you already know how to
work hard and smart then the last
variable is long hours now if you find
that you're working so many hours that
you click into the point where it's now
working backwards then then you found
breaking point so you'll notice I
prioritize sleep so I make sure I get
all the sleep that I need because I know
to perform optimally I have to do that
so if you've got some breaking point
where it's not fun and you want to go
take a break and you're you can tell
that your learning is slowing down cool
then you know that's the time to take a
break
I'm never bashful about taking time off
when I need it because I know how hard I
play leave it all out on the field every
day and because of that when I need a
break I'll take a break
do you like whatever feels right
whatever feels amazing that's what you
should be doing so my work hard work
smart work long hours is all about that
thing that I value not everybody has to
value that rule number three prioritize
sleep
why do you prioritize sleep so highly
just curious of what makes you so
committed to that and the science behind
it thank you for all you do I find that
I'm slower when I'm fatigued so I find
myself drifting I have more symptoms of
what we'll call ad ad D so that my
attention is just drift drift drifts and
then I find I'll read a sentence or
whatever and be like kind of to reread
the sentence like 10 times so that was
just going whoa I'm not as efficient as
I could be and then the other is I find
it a unique form of misery there is an
additional ring of hell that is saved
just for people who are fatigued I hate
it so much
so it's misery and I don't understand
people that live a life that is
miserable I just don't get it and then
on top of that I think you actually
accomplish less if you're fatigued so
you're putting more hours we're actually
getting less done per hour so if being
fatigued puts you at like 0.6 of what
your output could be and then being just
like incredibly well rested prioritizing
that puts you at you know it's I guess
mathematically I should be saying just 1
then like you have to make up 40% of the
number of hours and waking up early just
to break even and then you put misery on
top of that so that that's my end of one
experience is that I am so deadly
efficient when I'm rested that I just
get more
so comparing those suicide by side I get
I actually accomplished more rule number
four developed grit hey Tom I'm 20 years
old and I've done some real
soul-searching over the past few years I
am certain that I don't want the
conventional life and I want to do my
own thing but whenever I start something
I quit because I find I'm not really
passionate about it enjoying it but I
fear I may not just want it bad enough
how do I differentiate between being
honest with myself and just pure
laziness Jodie this is an amazing
question first of all it is addressed
brilliantly by Duckworth Angela
Duckworth in the book grit which you
guys gonna want to read that absolutely
phenomenal book and it breaks down how
it's a very natural process to begin
something to be very excited and then as
you go down that process to realize yeah
I actually don't like this it's not
giving me as much energy as I thought it
would is taking energy away and
therefore I want to give up and quit
that thing and she said if you do that
once or twice like hey so be it but if
you're doing it every time if you just
love that initial rush that excitement
of something new but the actual
nitty-gritty reality of getting good at
it of doing what michio kaku calls
having but power meaning you've set your
butt in the seat and you do the work if
that's really your problem and nothing
is interesting enough for you to sit
there and do the work you haven't
developed grit yet and so grit is the
ability to persevere to see things
through to go past the point at which it
is stopped being fun and it becomes
boring because you believe in your end
goal enough you're excited by what
you're trying to accomplish so much that
you're willing to fight through all of
that difficulty you're willing to fight
through the boredom you're willing to
fight through the unease that arises
when you step outside your comfort zone
you're doing things you're not good at
and things that are boring those are the
two things that I find killed most
people they just cannot handle the
things that make them go oh god like I'm
not very good at this and I'm feeling
really badly about myself and they
forget that they can get good on a long
enough timeline and then to inevitably
in any pursuit of greatness in any
endeavor where you're trying to gain
mastery you're gonna get bored because
practice is repetition it's doing
something over and over and over and
over to really train yourself to get to
the point where you're truly exceptional
and
just so much boredom inherent in that
process so building in the resilience to
see all that stuff through is the key
part of grit rule number five be
goal-oriented as Shakespeare noted
there's nothing good or bad but thinking
makes it so
there's nothing good or bad right
there's just stimulus and then there's a
response things happen right yeah but
people think that it is objectively a
certain way so now because they think it
is an object objectively a certain way
they feel they are supposed to react
based on those emotions that are getting
kicked up in their mind what I'm saying
is absolutely not those emotions may not
serve you they're certainly not aimed at
moving you towards your goal they're
jobs that keep you alive
plain and simple so that's not
necessarily very helpful in a modern
context so if you want to always be
moving towards your goal you want to be
optimized you've got to learn to get
control of your emotions you've got to
learn to understand to tell yourself a
narrative that isn't predicated on
necessarily identifying what is
objectively true because I don't think
that we experience the world that way
it's identifying what's going to work to
get me to my goal mm-hm and that to me
like my whole thing is goal first
everything else works backwards from
that mm-hmm I started from the like the
grand strategy like identifying it and
then building the steps backwards to
reverse engineering essentially correct
rule number six deliver results do you
have advice on creating a better future
without a college education yes so
here's the answer crystal you're going
to as of right now this moment you're
gonna focus entirely on one thing
getting so good you cannot be ignored
now what do I mean by that
getting Soviet you deliver results
deliver results for yourself to deliver
results for other people I would just
tell you every business owner on the
planet is looking for people that can
help them grow their business that's it
they care about one thing and one thing
only can you deliver results so the good
news here is you can always count on
humans to be selfish and I don't mean
that in a bad way I mean they're
passionate about the things that they're
passionate about they're trying to
accomplish the things they're trying to
accomplish and if you can show how you
can help with that
people are gonna want you no matter what
I don't give a [ __ ] if you have a
college education like that is so
irrelevant to me a college education
merely tells me that you've been
formally trained it doesn't tell me if
you're actually good
on a resume can be very powerful cuz
I'll look at that in a shorthand I'll
say oh like they probably are ahead of
somebody that doesn't have those things
but if you're out in the real world
getting results I'm all for that and let
me tell you how fast you can convey that
with something like if I'm like right
now hey everybody by the way PS if
you're a director of marketing we want
to hear from you especially if you
understand content marketing so I think
most people in this community know that
Jared has moved up to San Jose
I don't do remote employees he's chasing
his own thing that guy was amazing and
I'm super heartbroken that he left but
now we're looking for somebody to
replace him with and what I look for is
I look for people that have done I don't
I actually don't even look at their
college education I don't even scan that
far down in the resume I just want to
know what are you doing what have you
accomplished and like can you put
together a comp like what is the word
I'm late I'm having a stroke uh uh
comprehensive is in the word but I'm
gonna stick with it cohesive there we go
can you put together a cohesive coherent
resume which you'd be shocked how few
people actually can so put that together
maybe a super brief cover letter maybe
you hit the person up on social whatever
anyway it is really easy if you're
actually good it's really easy to
convince other people that you're
actually good so focus all your time and
energy on actually getting good rule
number seven my personal favorite
believe in yourself
how do I get over my block of I am never
good enough especially when my
significant other has high expectations
but does not support me in reaching
those expectations okay so we have two
issues so first of all getting over your
block of I'm not good enough for me the
thing that absolutely destroyed all of
that is my unflagging belief in one
simple thing I can learn anything so I
may not be good at that thing now I may
really not be good enough like when I
think about building a studio to rival
Disney I'm not good enough yet there's a
huge chasm and skill set between me and
Bob Iger and being able to do that I
fully understand that and I have to do
something different which is
this create all the energy whereas Bob
Iger came in wait I mean they've been in
business for like 75 years or something
by the time he came along so it is a
really intriguing skill set to be able
to both build and create something scale
it and then run it once it's big so I
know full well that I have not yet the
person that I need to be in order to do
that and so my time and energy is spent
in building that skill set so I don't
freak out over the fact that I'm not
good enough that's very easy for me to
admit I instead spend my time thinking
about how do i acquire those skills in
order to actually become good enough so
don't let your self-worth be tied up in
that notion of good enough humans are
the ultimate adaptation machine from
that I derive my sort of high-level
sense of worth that hey every human
being has worth because they're an
ultimate adaptation machine and they can
become anything they want that's just
really cool and amazing and then also I
just am deeply compassionate for the
human condition so yeah regardless of
where people fall on that path of
actually executing against that
potential I get it man being a human is
both beautiful amazing all this
potential and it's really hard so have
compassion for yourself which i think is
incredibly important and know that this
is hard and then believe that you can
become anything that you set your mind
to and then just be honest with yourself
you don't have to want to be the
greatest in the world so whether you let
somebody else apply those high standards
to you or not is completely your choice
just remember it's a choice and you're
not not great because you can't be
you're not great because you haven't
applied yourself to that so that is the
key for me like understanding that my
life is an exact reflection of my
choices is entirely liberating so
remember your life is an exact
reflection of your choices if you want a
different result you simply need to make
a different choice rule number eight
adopt a growth mindset a fixed mindset
somebody that has a fixed mindset
believes that their talent and
intelligence or fixed traits that
whatever you're born with that's it
those are gonna be that's as good as
you're ever gonna be and so hey make the
most of it somebody that has a growth
mindset realizes that that's just you're
starting off point and while we may not
all be equal from where our starting off
point is the human animal is literally
designed
the ground up to be able to adapt and so
it begins to be a question of how much
are you willing to adapt what price are
you willing to pay to get great at
something rule number nine move towards
your dreams what if you're happy with
your job but you don't like the place
it's in and the honest answer for me is
I would leave like I'm so held but like
I know what I want to do with my life
it is so clear to me that I just
wouldn't let anything stop me and that's
why I left Tacoma
I love Tacoma I was not unhappy in
Tacoma at all like people always think I
left for the weather or whatever I
didn't even think about the weather as a
kid it was oh I knew I left because I
wanted to be in a bigger city that had
more opportunity and that was it and so
I was moving towards something and I
think that there are two things that
motivate people moving away from
something so oh I don't want that to
happen I don't want like take longevity
I don't want to die that's moving away
from something I want to live forever
that's moving towards something so
living forever for me is about all the
things that I could do and all that so
I'm moving towards that I'm not moving
away from a fear of death so that here
like the only perspective I can give you
is that if I ever had a sense of like I
can't go as far as I want to go in this
place I would be gone in a heartbeat and
rule number ten the last one before two
very special bonus Clips is choose your
reality as friends kafka said you are
free that is why you are lost look
around you there are no guardrails on
your life the reality is that people
have tried to paint a picture for you
that says that there are certain things
that are right they've tried to paint a
world for you that has a path well laid
for it for you to follow go to school
get good grades get a degree get a job
we retire that's the plan that everybody
wants you to believe is really the plan
but the reality is
that you are free to choose anything you
want the reality is that you can go in
any path you want the reality is that
path is an illusion the truth of life is
you can go anywhere you want you can be
anything that you want you can become
anyone you want to become at the end of
the day the choice is yours at the end
of the day you get to construct yourself
you get to decide what it is that you
want to believe as long as you're not
violating the laws of physics even
physics is a game of maybe even physics
is uncertain and unknown at the end of
the day everything that you get to do
you get to choose you get to create you
get to build something that you want to
be and in that that's where people get
lost they don't understand that the
control is theirs they're lost because
they think there's a path they think
there's a way forward and emotionally it
doesn't resonate emotionally they're
unable to make it feel real because it
doesn't feel real they feel lost they're
unsure they don't know where to go or
who to become or even who they are and
that sense of being lost comes from the
freedom of being able to choose anything
you want but no one told you that you
could choose but as Tupac Shakur said
reality is wrong dreams are for real
it's the dream that you want to focus on
the dream does your ability to construct
that path the dream is you saying this
is the way that I want to walk the dream
is you saying all of this nothingness
all of this mass confusion all of this
probability and uncertainty I am going
to manifest something real and concrete
and directional in my life I choose to
be Who I am I choose to be who I become
I choose to build something with my
hands to create something that has never
been seen before to do something that
people have never done before
to believe in things that other people
cannot see that dream is my reality that
dream is what I'm going to bring into
existence that dream is the thing that I
believe in
and in believing in that dream and
building that path and finding out in
deciding who you want to be for the
first time you will find yourself in
yourself coming
so go become what you want to be don't
worry about walking somebody else's path
now I've got two really special Tom bill
you clips are on how to know what not to
do and assess where you actually are but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from Tom today what was a single
biggest insight you're gonna apply
somehow to your life or business
put it down the comments below when you
write it down you're much more likely to
actually do the work so leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
80% of business is knowing what not to
do that's the really hard part most
people have no dearth of opportunities
and I think that that has certainly been
true in my life I think that that's
certainly true for most people the real
hard part is being in that room of the
thousand doors and knowing which doors
to close so you have to get really good
at creating certainty at being decisive
at being willing to take a step and when
it comes to that honestly the thing that
I've noticed most is just a willingness
I'm trying to survive the tail end of an
illness here the willingness to make a
decision even when you don't have all
the information that's really where we
separate the people that go on to win
from the people that just stand still
because remember the most data rich
information stream is action whether
that action is a win or a loss it's
somewhat irrelevant the whole point is
you have to be moving forward you have
to be acting decisively because that
gives you that data rich information
stream most people are so terrified to
make a mistake they're so paralyzed by
indecision because they don't know which
is right that they never make a decision
they never hit that data rich stream and
they don't learn very fast and so they
move 10 times 20 times a hundred times
more slowly than the next person who's
willing to act who's willing to make
mistakes who's not afraid to look stupid
so that's the key as I'm sure you've
heard said the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself
I will modify that and say the only
thing that we have to fear is indecision
do I need to have a solid idea of the
person I am today in order to be the
person I want to become yes I think that
would be very powerful for you the
ability to accurately self assess is
incredibly powerful now people that have
the highest levels of self delusion also
have the highest levels of happy
which is one of the great ironies of
being a human so this is advanced class
yet but you don't want to spend too much
time looking really Rowley at where you
are and how bad you are at this thing
that you're trying to do but at the same
time you do need to be able to
accurately assess where you are now the
key that I've found to being able to
stare at naked ly your inadequacies is
that you have to build your self-esteem
around something else
but when yourself esteem is tied around
this it can be pretty gnarly emotionally
to spend a lot of time looking at that
which is why people don't do it but if
you build your self-esteem around this
little thing here that I'm doing with my
fingers which is the willingness to look
at that to get better to sincerely apply
yourself to getting better to recognize
that the only difference between who you
want to be and who you are as a set of
skills and that you can acquire those
skills but first you have to understand
where you actually are and where you're
trying to go and then being able to
identify that chasm that you have to
cross and if you take your pride your
self-esteem from the willingness to
cross that chasm then suddenly you
actually get self-esteem by looking at
that by assessing where you really are
and so that is one of the most powerful
things anybody can do if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon table Eve nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]